[Music]
oh hey what's up again uh we've been
working on this video for like non-stop
two weeks now Oh smart video so we did
our brand integrations we have plenty of
time to turn them around a lot funny you
know this pub G video in particular we
have three weeks shooting it to
finishing it do you finish it early we
need to finish it in time to send off
companies some to look at the video just
thumbs up
that means being really on top of things
and the only way we're gonna get this
done is to actually coordinate the
entire studio to work on this project
all at the same time I make a task
manager this is a multi-core processor
and I'm translating out which attacks
should go where and like kind of
thinking like that this Testament is
going to take Clan to three hours and
this task is going to take Adrienne one
hour then how do i balance that out how
what do I have Adrienne do pose next two
hours it's been challenging doing these
kind of video game videos is what I
loved we're we're filmmakers that are
very inspired by video games and if if
we fail out this we like if we can't
kick this done in time the team can't
work together not only doesn't mean that
we're not cut out to do what we want to
do it also means that this whole growing
the suti and growing the team thing may
not be working out as well as you
planned I don't think it's going to
happen the channel is not going to get
deleted but that's that's the thing it's
like we need to prove ourselves in this
project we're proving that as a team
we're gonna do a good work and we can do
it fast and we can do it good this is
that twice I said good twice um well
Michael I hear you're acting like
gravure it's hard to focus on five
different things if you're tried you
only have two eyeballs and they usually
focus on one thing unfortunately we just
don't have the same time that you would
on a short film where you might have
like a week or two to do an entire color
grid I have a day and a half two looks
inside the force field and outside the
force field
what is
color what is color green to me it's the
best part of the filmmaking process
you basically have like this plan
looking thing you're looking at
something for so long look so blend
suddenly putting on sunglasses that just
saturate your image and it makes
everything beautiful imagine seeing
everything black and white your whole
life and then something just putting on
glasses and everything just becomes
colorful back that's all colors they can
create tone mood you can create a unique
look you can use color as a storytelling
device going into Vinci building a lot
going back into premiere creating an
adjustment layer bringing in that look
that you just created onto the
adjustment layer blocking that layer and
then going into individual Clips to
tweak certain exposures change the ISO
because we're still working with like
the raw files is this the only way or
the even the right way to do color
correction definitely not but is it a
quick way and is it an efficient way I
would say so
you can freeze an American yeah man I
got my lucky bamboo MIT
but I'm just trying to stay as chill as
possible it's pretty much my life goal
our use in order to use it I'm not one
thing it's a form of self-care resting
relaxing stretching yoga rock climbing I
like to go home and just rest on a block
and it stretches my background I like
therapy balls that I'll press my neck on
I mean this way I was standing this I
like to get massages a lot I like to go
to the spa on
I like we spa go to we smile a lot we
spas in k-town it's a four-story 24-hour
spot it's the best thick manicures
pedicures body scrub facials like all
that good stuff have a hot tub they have
super hot tub a cold pool they're
telling the super hot tub one's much
hotter but why I call it the soup can I
ride this real quick yeah so here's the
battery think it's Bastide
better than the toaster
what do you spell Oh me dude traders
potpies are great do one more solo run
[Music]
dude that was dude I love weird you get
your tea from mine
gotcha but seriously sure it's covered
in dirt so you know that's dressed up
right now
no we're gonna make her we're gonna make
your time yeah we're gonna we're gonna
make it
well three hours left in the day one day
left on top of today I
seven more shots to get to a
work-in-progress leveled out to Kevin
who's doing our sound so he knows where
to put gunshots and bullet hit someone
on fire sent a VFX sound pass I'm
thinking about hitting all the things
that would require sound it has the
gunshots it has the muzzle flashes right
it has the bullet hits not even
rotoscoping it's not even like touching
up anything some some people go as quick
as doing little squares in any corner of
the frame or square on the gun one frame
in Premiere just to get it out to sound
you know you don't even need to do all
this for me it's fine do this anyway we
all do a lot of different stuff it's
easy for us to get the VFX halfway there
and send it to Kevin it works a stylist
uh-huh over a mouse hole besides the
fact that it saves your wrist from
deteriorating that's the main benefit
the other benefit is I find it faster
gun visual effects Hollywood still sucks
at viola it's because and really the key
to doing a good gun effect is to just go
out there and shoot guns be familiar
with how they work and I don't think a
lot of visual effects artists do that
I'm sure some do but the ones that do
the gun effects certainly aren't while
there's people out there who are amazing
at visual effects far better than I am I
can safely say that salmon myself are
the best at gun visual effects this is
pure confidence guys what's there
between confidence and arrogance backing
it up backing it up that's like
Carmichael's confident say most enter
between confidence and arrogance results
oh we're not talking like specifically
muzzle flip you're talking like the gun
hits and like
I've been learning from these guys for
that me and San effects guys are gonna
figure that yeah although I really I
would caution you
you're gonna sing that or posting
anything of you saying that in this
video what that's going to do is going
to bring extreme scrutiny for the VFX in
this video which I do personally believe
are not actually at a class level it's
not because of the skill thing but it's
because of a time constraint the actual
gun effects in the pubsey video just cuz
it not saying they're bad I look at them
I'm like if you really wanted to go like
if that extra like it's missing that
what would you do to get that well the
cloudy blood hits are cool but I think
they're to circa 2011 the cloudy blood
hit thing though that was leave that to
death there's so many other ways to do
squids you do the chunky ones you do
local little pieces stuff like that
decals the last thing effect of the
environment we already went like decals
with both bullet holes and blood hits
but all stuff requires extensive 3d
tracking and like masking and stuff like
that which Sam is right we don't have
the time to do on this project really
the true like outside of like decals
which played this like the true effect
of guns working welcomes from the impact
they make that impact happens here on
the body not on the gun it happens on
both ends the gun is the tool throwing a
piece of metal at Mach two and then the
rock or the body or whatever that is
hitting is a thing that's receiving the
impact so are you watching the gun being
shot are you watching the stunt guy do
the crazy backflip as he falls down from
the gunfire well both because you have a
shot one and they cut to the shot the
next but 2001 I it looks that way at the
gun that way that's the guy
well no it's editing I'm playing devil's
advocate a little bit does anyone get
headshot in this video yeah no have to
be done by the end of today and we've
got not enough time I can do a million
VFX shots in like a minute
Sam's not kidding I'll do in the effects
track I'll do gun one gunshot hits the
one that I can do yes claim what I have
like 15 minutes to do a VFX shot cuz I
have to head out a little early today
what shot should I do I want to do like
a really really like shot whoa
I stood by Jake with a pistol over the
rock okay cool great he'll do it so I
need to let's see if it's a head shot
though cuz you're looking for a head
I'll make it a shot so supposedly he's
done with the whole shot with Sam white
already no way no way I call shenanigans
here's the thing Sam is really good at
effects Annie he's faster anyone I know
but he brings it's like 80% well I don't
want I don't want to be mean Sam's very
good at effects I wanted to clarify that
that's what I've got going into this
I've got strict glasses a classic
artisan B issue you know where does the
jank thing where you get your jank Hank
go on yet Serena's just [ __ ]
blasphemous treatement not gonna lie Sam
I came in here with like doubts being
like you only spent 15 minutes on this
shot I don't know how it's gonna look
and it's pretty solid thanks I really
appreciate that
dude red giant they got it all they got
all the best plugins tell you guys a
secret I haven't done visual effects
well it's basically gonna visual effects
for like over two years now ever since
Ren joined he's really alleviated a lot
of the work off my plate but it's time
to come back time to come out of
retirement for this shot right here I
want tell you some of the tips and
tricks and secrets to making this stuff
look good you'll notice in this shot
there's bullet hits that seem to have
shading on them they're casting shadows
they feel like they're connected to the
environment and if you've ever tried
doing some these effects yourself
probably wondered why when you start out
it doesn't look so good if I make your
background footage drop it in you grab
one of your ground hit elements that
maybe you get from action VFX or action
essentials you drop that in all i need's
transparency so you put it on the screen
mode or something and you got yourself
cool bullet hit and it looks really fake
yeah right eat of his motion tracked it
doesn't look like it's supposed to be
there does it so I'm gonna show you a
secret dick gun effects and what I do to
make this stuff look good what I do to
make it feel like it's part of the scene
dude if you're not doing visual effects
interesting to see how people create
reality and Bend reality with their shot
it's like watching a painter sit down
and paint a filter real painting it's at
the end of the day when it comes to
making good visual effects it's the same
disappointment you're going to be
inventing something with your tools and
with your mind that looks real so you
need to know about real life and how to
represent it and make it look real if
you can draw a good picture if you can
paint a nice picture you can definitely
first things first I'll talk about these
bullet hits here coming off this rock so
there's a lot of things you want to
think about when making a bullet hit
look good you need a good element so
you're going to drop in some of the best
ones are either from actual essentials
but they're really kind of old by now
and used by everybody or action VFX
which is a VFX stock footage company
based in the UK and they're really
putting on some really solid stuff once
you drop the stuff in it's going to need
work to make it look good here's some of
the things to think about but so you
just have the footage your background
footage here and you drop in an element
in this case I'm gonna grab the elements
wall side hits three boom it's in now I
did some motion tracking here you can
track points in After Effects we can
track little areas in mocha it's not
very hard to track a point in a scene so
if you're going to have a bullet hit or
an impact in your scene need to track
the point where it's going to hit so it
sticks there if your cameras moving
basic stuff but one of the first steps
to making things look like the part of
the environment secondly you have your
element in there it doesn't look real
it's in there right now it's just like
it looks like a piece of footage paste
it on top we got to start making it look
real in drawing they talked about making
a drawing on a piece of paper you're
connecting it to the page and you
connect something to the page with a
shadow so anytime you add two elements
you really want to feel like it's
connected to the environment you need to
add a shadow there we go
suddenly it feels like this dust is
actually there on top of the rock it
looks pretty solid but you know what
still kind of flat like look at the dirt
all around us here there's all these
different tonalities there's white
incoming in a certain direction and this
dust it just it's just kind of one color
even though it has some depth to it now
there's a shadow there it's just not
reading I'm gonna add another elements
it from the same pack so I'm going to
add wall side hit 11 Wow here's the
thing so this element I added behind the
other one it's a slightly different
color it didn't come that way I made it
that way you have you have basic ways to
the gesture color I just use hue and
saturation and they also added some
levels to thicken the effect because I
didn't do levels on the color channels I
did levels on the Alpha channels you can
treat your alpha channels like a black
and white image and increase the
contrast to increase the contrast
brightness darken it and it will affect
your transparency accordingly now these
two elements layered together feel a
little bit more robust it feels a little
bit less up like I just pasted a piece
of footage on my shot and like I'm
actually getting an element craft
we shot but you know what it's still
super flat this is my number one secret
this is the thing that I teach everybody
when they come into court or they start
doing gun effects I duplicate it again
and I draw a mass around half of it from
that look from the direction the light
is coming from and if I want to I can
also brighten it a little bit this
little trick of just duplicating it and
masking it gives it volume and gives it
shape it actually starts making it look
like it's being shaded from the light
and this is where a little bit that
drawing and painting like know how it
comes into play do you think about like
drawing a sphere on a piece of paper and
you give it a light direction oh I'm
gonna put the shadow over here and I
shade the sphere here it's the same
thing from these elements do you think
about them existing in this world this
element be lit by the Sun yeah probably
it's out there under the Sun which
direction would it be lit from what
would the colors be like how bright
would it be not done yet that little
shading a bit looks great until the
smoke starts thinning out so once once
the dust gets thinner it shouldn't
really be picking up a thick volumetric
kind of look so I just simply he framed
transparency starts at 100 goes down to
about 20% and sits that through the rest
of the shot nice it's dark element
behind it that kind of needed shadow too
so I added one of those as well and to
add a shadow it's pretty simple all I
did to add a shadow was take my element
duplicate it blur it oh and I put out
multiply now as shadows in real life
could be different colors depending on
the color of your ambient light in this
case I did just a slight shift back
towards purplish oranges because blue
sky tends to make your shadows blue or
you can always look at the shadows and
you're seeing the real shadows for
reference all that together pretty much
makes it look like this hit is part of
the shot there's one last thing I did
last a little bit of magic here is a
little bit of a bullet hit pink like
their head it's a camera shake actually
is the second pass for when the hit
happens which helps make it feel like
it's part of the scene it also hides all
my small mistakes a good VFX artist is
always looking to the elements in their
scene that are real for reference to
make sure your colors match these
elements will give you really good
looking bullet impacts if you can hit
all those check marks and hit all those
boxes turn everything back on here
[Music]
Sam